another trailer another video to talk
about if you're gonna say in this video
that I look like I just woke up or
looked tired like you said in the last
video I got one thing to say very
observant that's exactly the case good
job so the zombies gonna talk about this
trailer and it's Captain Marvel which I
love the fact that when that suit was
revealed I don't even know if it was an
official reveal or some TMZ person and
the bush is taking pictures point is
that suit was revealed in the Internet
oh my god did the internet hate that
suit although they were like fine five
here's her and her other suit doesn't
raise the fact this trailer doubles down
with the greenish suit because she
crashed lands to earth like Abin Sur
before her and it was a different
universe she launched Padma quacks
herself onto earth which hey Carol miss
Danvers falling through a roof is bad
luck please leave the premises before
you jinx the company and they go under
or something the point is samuel
l.jackson meets up with her it's like
are you from her she's like I don't know
I have dreams of Earth so you kind of
get the feeling that you like Peter
quill but unlike Peter quill she doesn't
really know that she's from her was she
hanging around with a bunch of aliens
going there's something different about
me I don't know to which she lands on a
world with people who are like her and
she's like it's you know this is kind of
weird there's something familiar about
them they look like my mirror is it a
parent that I don't know much about
Captain Marvel story it's true I do know
Jude Law plays Marvel I know that his
name is actually Marvel like Marvel
Marvel it's kind of like a dad joke my
favorite part of trailers when she's
like [ __ ] your dentures which cannot
have been an actual grandma isn't she's
super strong miss Marvel is how rogue
got her flight invulnerability and super
strength right which this movie I
believe it takes place in the 90s I
thought it was the 80s but then I quit
google it and a quick google caption was
the 90s I believe it's the 90s but are
they gonna do the young face samuel
l.jackson cgi face that Marvel does
they're great at it they're only getting
better at it generally speaking samuel
l.jackson doesn't really look his age he
looks younger than he is he doesn't have
a goatee where they just like just shave
the goatee Sam you'll be fine I asked
because I'm trying to gauge how much
screen time Samuel Jackson's gonna have
in this movie like young CGI face
doesn't have a lot of screen time in
these movies also has no screen time
during action sequences so how they just
improved their craft of young CGI face
so he can be in the movie more or is he
just gonna be a small cameo in the movie
we got young Coulson who I imagine is
just gonna be a cameo but Nick Fury's a
huge part of all of it he even gives her
the Captain Marvel Batphone little pager
we saw the end of infinity war
honest with myself and you which I
should always be this trailer didn't do
much for me like it didn't hook me I
didn't walk away from this girl and
that's gonna be so good so badass she is
so badass
I feel like this trailers one function
is simply an announcement for Marvel to
be like we have our strong female led
superhero movie now - that's not Elektra
DC has Wonder Woman who do we have we're
behind so now they have Captain Marvel
the problem with all this and not a
problem for DC is that a lot of people
know who Wonder Woman is not a lot of
people know who Captain Marvel is so
where the reaction was oh [ __ ] a Wonder
Woman movie looks cool now people are
like who's Captain Marvel so this
trailer should have shown us why we
should give a [ __ ] about Captain Marvel
it should have shown us why this is this
strong character we should care about
but after this I know nothing about her
quest I really know very little about
her I know this is the first trailer and
the movie comes out in a few months so
it all depends on how you want to look
at that the movies still a few months
out also phrase the movies only a few
months out feel like we should care
about her a little more the teaser
trailer for Wonder Woman showed Wonder
Woman kicking copious amounts of ass
even show that iconic scene where she's
on the battlefield taking the bullets
with her shield that [ __ ] is awesome and
here is the mind job that teaser trailer
for Wonder Woman that showed all that
came out nearly a year before Wonder
Woman day so this trailer could have
been a bit better as it stands now I
feel like this trailer is just Marvel
pleading with audiences we have strong
female characters not sitting it out if
turning her into hero doesn't say that I
don't know what does yeah something like
that would you take Iron Man 1 so many
people did not know who Iron Man was
Tony Stark was not a household name but
with that trailer Robert Downey jr.
crushed it and then people gave a [ __ ]
this trailer didn't have anything like
that so anyhow those are my thoughts on
it I thought it was kind of a weak
trailer not that it looks terrible I
mean Marvel is pretty reliable in their
entertainment so I feel like this movie
will be entertained but I feel like this
should have come out the gate swinging
and I don't feel like the trailer did
that right so the trailer for Captain
Marvel have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]